so let's start talking about
um heart health and cholesterol because
that's a little bit newer information so
what do you what have you learned about
that why is that such a passion for you
now
yeah it's a passion because I I
personally think the Cardiology as a
medical profession is the most corrupt
medical profession I hate to say it
because there's probably some
cardiologists watching this right now
I'm not saying everybody who's a
cardiologist is corrupt but that
profession in particular it's unusually
corrupt why is it uh I think it's
because
they tell people they're gonna die
unless they get on statins
right and that's the best sales pitch in
the world I mean imagine you went to the
car mechanic rich and you had to you
know and he said look we need to change
your oil or your car is going to explode
and you're gonna die well that's a good
sales pitch like you're sure as hell
gonna change your oil right
like if you can use death as a marketing
tool
and tell people they're gonna die unless
they get on some fake prescription drug
that's not found in nature you're going
to sell a ton of product and that's
exactly what they do and that's almost
exclusively what they do day to day they
just tell everybody your cholesterol is
too high let's get you on statins and
they usually wait three buckets for
prescribing statins
that depends on the the state and the
the yes for the most part yes
like directly monit like with money or
is it hey we're doing a retreat in
Hawaii for four weeks so we're going to
take you along Dr Smith
it depends I mean usually it's direct I
mean the hospitals get kicked back so
then the doctors get Kickbacks but it's
it's not like if you prescribe 10 of
these you get
10 times more money or something but
right you know their salaries blow up
and what a lot of them to do exactly
they just lower cholesterol
so they lower your they block your
body's ability to make cholesterol and
you need cholesterol to manage your
endocrine system don't you it's like the
building block for testosterone it's the
building block for just not all your sex
hormones exactly exactly and and you
know vegans this is another strike
against veganism because
their total cholesterol is usually super
super low right like 110 120 and you
know what the doctors tell those people
they say oh I'm so proud of you that's
so good in fact are we able to screen
share on this thing or not really uh at
the bottom you should be able to hit
present
oh yeah present okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
show you a study if I can um yeah so if
you just hit present and throw it up on
the screen I think you'll be able to do
it yeah let me let me minimize and pull
up a study I've got it right here so it
shouldn't be too hard to find
it's it's saying okay when no
cholesterol studies
yeah good
um and do you see my my screen right now
on the cluster I'll get good
yeah I'm just getting this out of the
way perfect so you see the title of this
study right total cholesterol and all
cause mortality so what they're they're
just looking at your total cholesterol
and this study is the gold standard it's
got 12.8 million people giant study
right and all cause mortality that's
just a fancy scientific way of saying
death they don't want to say death but
they're saying they're studying what's
your total cholesterol and not just
what's your risk of heart attacks but
what's your total cholesterol what's
your risk of dying by any cost so it
could be heart attacks but it could be
Strokes could be cancer could be
anything all right and again 12 million
people is a giant study
um I just want to show you one graph
from the study right and it's it's right
here it's figure two I'm gonna try and
blow it up here
um
and you can see this total cholesterol
men and women Hazard ratio on the left
Hazard ratio that means Hazard of dying
by any cause right you don't want a high
Hazard ratio it could be it could be
higher cancer could be higher uh heart
attacks could be higher whatever but you
don't want a high Hazard ratio this just
means a high risk of death now
if you're if you're a vegan your total
cholesterol is almost always 110 to 120
right
and
look at how terrible that is in terms of
your hazard ratio that's literally the
worst Hazard ratio you can have that
doubles your risk of death
but you know what the doctor is going to
tell you what your cardiologist is going
to say if you go in there with a 110 I
guarantee you they're going to tell you
I'm so proud of you your cholesterol is
amazing good job
are they lying or are they just
misinformed they're just mistrained
that's just what they're taught to say
that's what they think they think lower
is better and they get hammered with
this in med school and they get laughed
at if they think anything different you
know
uh it's kind of like the covet stuff
it's like if they're taught if if if
they're saying
something different than what the
government says everybody laughs at him
and says they're wrong and all this
there's a lot of peer pressure in this
but you know what's the craziest part of
this is if your total cholesterol gets
above 200 check your blood work it'll
say it they flag it they say it's too
high they tell you it's terrible you got
to get on statins or you're going to die
honestly that's literally the best range
right you can see where the hazard ratio
is the lowest is above 200. anywhere
between like 180 and 280 I'm as happy as
could be that's exceptional that's great
that's good for your testosterone it's
good for everything
um
and again your hormones are made from
this so if you're down here in the vegan
range
right
uh your hormones are going to be super
low your sex hormones so the vegans
complain about this the doctor will say
oh good job you're doing so good your
cholesterol is amazing your blood work
looks great and then of course they
don't check their testosterone right but
the vegan will say yeah but I have no
sex drive and I have no energy and the
doctor will say oh strange because your
blood work looks really good now I'll
look at their blood work and say no it
doesn't look good at all right I want to
get you above 200 let's start eating
saturated fat let's start eating lots of
bacon okay so total cholesterol over 200
so so what would be the max rain like
like the higher the better or no 300 is
starting to go back up right okay so 200
to 300 is good so I'm going to keep an
eye on this with my own so thank you for
that
um that's that's interesting well and
I've had clients Rich that are 400 500
on their total cholesterol that's way
too high right the hazard ratio starts
to scope now usually they have genetic
issues where that's that's their weak
spot and those people I still don't tell
them to go on statins right like you I
tell those people to go vegan you know
honestly if your cholesterol is 500 it's
probably damaging your arteries and the
reason for that by the way here's how
they do it in med school I've taken the
classes I've tutored the classes I've
taught the classes right here's what
they do
um I used to be very conventional in my
thinking too by the way but I've just
shifted a lot over the years and it's
been a slow process for me but
they tell you
look there's a genetic mutation that
causes familial hypercholesterolemia
what does that mean it means your
cholesterol is outrageously high right
like 500 your total cholesterol and in
those people you see heart attacks at
age 30. you know like you legitimately
see early heart attacks really young
um therefore cholesterol is bad
cholesterol cars is heart attacks if
it's high it's bad lower is better
that's kind of the foundation for the
way they think on this
um
but here's the thing if you have super
high cholesterol it reacts with oxygen
in your body right like you've got red
blood cells carrying oxygen and it
becomes oxidized if it stays in your
body long enough and your liver can't
clear it out it starts to become
oxidized and the cholesterol itself
becomes inflammatory and remember
inflammation is always the root cause of
plaque in the arteries so you end up
with inflammation you end up with
damaged arteries
the cholesterol is physically there in
the arteries I mean it it fixes the
damage
and so they they say look in those cases
you lower that cholesterol with statins
usually that's what they do
um in those the risk of heart attack
goes away and that's true and you don't
have to use the statins to do that you
can use the vegan diet to do that or
manage that at least get it down to 200
and then start changing your diet back
but
um but the point is like when it's
outrageously high it's still not the
cholesterol it's the inflam it's the
inflammation from the high cholesterol
does that make sense have cholesterol
levels changed over the last 50 or six
years like is this you know something
they monitor kind of like testosterone
levels you mentioned with that study
back in the 1980s
yeah uh
I I I'm not sure I mean they do monitor
it in fact in that exact study uh let me
see if I can share the screen again and
hopefully it's still on that same image
um in that study they actually have data
uh [__] I closed it but they show the
the average male or the average female
here I'll pull it back up because then
otherwise I'm just yeah I just hit the
present button at the bottom there and
it'll pop up on my end so I can put in
the screen
yeah I accidentally closed the whole PDF
but I just got it so there you go so I'm
going to go back to that same page we
were just on and you see the top of the
the page here with these two graphs it
says mean total cholesterol mean TC that
means like basically the average in
median TC so the the average total
cholesterol was measured in this study
for men and women you can see at age you
know 40
the average uh man is usually about 195.
you see that that big green line
and the average women at age 40 is
usually about 180. so they have this
data right and so with age it tends to
go up a little bit because your sex
hormones start to go down a little bit
so so your body increases cholesterol
in response to that right your body's
trying to make more hormones it's trying
to stay optimized
um but in terms of like you asked about
you know from 1980s or whatever I don't
know I don't I've never looked into the
historical Trends
um I'm sure they there's probably a bit
of a story there interesting I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out